bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 23 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale avec nos invités
également les journalistes de la
rédaction commence tout de suite avec
les titres de cette édition
aujourd'hui a eu lieu le conseil
d'installation d'un nouvel epci
établissement public de coopération
inter départementale des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine patrick devedjian et
pierre bédier ont été élus
respectivement président et vice
président de ce conseil
une première étape concrète du
rapprochement entre les deux
départements et ce matin thierry mandon
le secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'enseignement et de la recherche était
en visite sur le plateau de saclay un
moyen de célébrer l'entrée en tutelle de
l'ue vs qu avec la plateforme de
recherche
ipanema du cnrs situé au 50 rue mont
soleil ce laboratoire étudie les
matériaux anciens depuis 2010 et enfin
samedi 26 mars aux clayes-sous-bois les
adhérents de l'association des
diabétiques des yvelines tiendront leur
assemblée générale annuelle
occasion de présenter les avancées
technologiques pour aider les
diabétiques dans leur traitement
pour nous en parler notre invité de ce
soir martine morival présidente de
l'association des diabétiques et des
yvelines et pour commencer tout d'abord
à ce journal cette information la nuit
dernière a été particulièrement agitée à
plaisir six voitures ont été incendiées
dans deux quartiers de la ville trois
véhicules ont été brûlés vers une heure
dans la résidence est daniel à proximité
de l'école maternelle anna de noailles
vers 2h c'est la résidence gabriel qui a
été touchée à son tour
trois autres voitures ont flambé rue de
la ferronnerie la cause de ces incendies
pardon n'est pas encore connue cyan et
suite aux attentats survenus ce mardi
matin à bruxelles en belgique des moyens
supplémentaires ont été déployés
rapidement dans les yvelines pour
renforcer la vigilance sur les sites
touristiques les centres commerciaux et
toutes les gares du département des
forces de police ont été mobilisés
immédiatement notamment dans les gares
de versailles hier lors des patrouilles
dans les gares de versailles chantiers
et sur les quais des policiers
distribué un petit guide sur la conduite
à tenir face à un risque terroriste
le premier conseil a observé et bien sûr
de prévenir les forces de sécurité en
cas de comportement suspect ou de colis
suspect en composant le 17 ou le 112 est
ce matin à vélizy les élus yvelinois et
alto-séquanais étaient réunis pour la
séance d'installation du conseil
d'administration de l'établissement
public de coordination inter
départementale des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
au programme élection du président
présentation des différentes commissions
un premier rapprochement entre les deux
départements les précisions de william l
une élection sans surprise ce matin
patrick devedjian a été élu président du
conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
pierre bédier a pris ses fonctions de
vice-président de sept pays qui aura son
siège dans la commune de vélizy symbole
de la jonction entre les deux
départements
on n'est pas encore dans une fusion on
est simplement dans un processus de
rapprochement
nous avons un instrument pour travailler
ensemble et déterminer ce que pourra
être dans l'avenir
une fusion si nous réussissons à la
mener à son terme création qualifiée
d'historique par son président les 80
membres seront répartis en 4 collèges
élus acteurs socioprofessionnels
personnalités qualifiées et associations
ces commissions ne se réunion autant que
de besoin
nous avançons pas à pas avec pragmatisme
et aussi de grande détermination parce
que nous sommes vraiment convaincu que
la région parisienne est en panne elle
est en panne de développement économique
et que l'association de ces deux
départements
c'est une réponse d'intérêt génère un
rapprochement qui tend vers une fusion
discuté au sein même de la majorité
ma principale crainte c'est
l'éloignement des centres de décision
aujourd'hui les yvelines oil ils
viennent à versailles la préfecture elle
est à versailles demain si on avait une
fusion des deux départements
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faudra
aller jusqu à nanterre je trouve
contradictoires à la fois d'avoir
augmenter massivement les impôts pour
garantir notre indépendance est ensuite
venir se marier avec les hauts de seine
un rapprochement qui a déjà commencé
avant la création de sept pays les
services d'archéologie avec déjà
fusionné
il en sera de même pour le parc
automobile en ce qui concerne les
prochaines réunions aucun calendrier n'a
encore été avancée l annonce avait déjà
été faite il ya quelques semaines par la
présidente du conseil régional d'île de
france valérie pécresse
la région ne reprendra pas l'opievoy à
sa charge
en effet le bailleur social victime
aujourd'hui de la loi allure n'existera
plus soul à sa forme actuelle et sera
donc dissout certains départements comme
le val d'oise donc leur attacher leur
logement alors office hlm départemental
dont les yvelines n'existe pas pierre
bédier le président de l'opi voit cette
entrevue s'est entretenu pardon avec les
dirigeants de la structure la semaine
dernière on les coûts tout de suite il
était au micro de williams elle donc
l'opievoy va se scinder en une partie
qui ira vers l'office départemental du
val d'oise c'est la partie qui déjà n'en
parle d'oiseaux du patrimoine en val
d'oise le patrimoine de l'essonne et des
yvelines
sera regroupé dans une entité qui ne
peut pas être nos fils public puisque
c'est la loi
elle interdit l'inter départementale it
est donc ce sera une société anonyme
je précise que les règles de gestion de
la société anonyme hlm et des règles de
gestion de l'office public hlm sont très
proches donc le plus important c'est
qu'il n'y aura ni licenciement ni
hausses de loyer et ce matin
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines a célébré son entrée en
tutelle avec elne ipanema situé au
synchrotron soleil sur le plateau de
saclay ce laboratoire étudie les
matériaux anciens depuis 2010
archéologie paléontologie et patrimoine
culturel pour officialiser cette union
le président de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines a
accompagné le secrétaire d'état chargé
de l'enseignement et de la recherche
siri mondon pour une visite du
laboratoire camille lambert était sur
place regarder mercredi 23 mars journée
célébration à l'ipa nema du plateau de
saclay depuis le 1er mars à cette
plateforme de recherche européenne
dédiée à l'étude des matériaux anciens
est devenu partenaire de l'université de
versailles saint quentin
pour l'occasion le secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'enseignement supérieur a
fait la visite du laboratoire un moyen
de mettre à l'honneur le domaine méconnu
des sciences du patrimoine pour nous
c'était très important de recevoir la
visite
damman du ministre monsieur thierry
mandon parce que c'était une manière de
reconnaître le travail accompli depuis
maintenant plusieurs années
le fait qu'il soit venu qui se sont
engagés personnellement ça montre à quel
point ce qu'on essaye de bâtir a lu vs
qu au plateau de saclay plus
généralement ile de france dans cette
thématique là c'est quelque chose qui a
vocation est de rayonnement
international dans notre domaine
la participation de l'université comme
versa et saint-quentin donne cette
garantie là le fait que ça va devenir
une matière à part entière que des
étudiants seront dirigés vers des études
de recherche dans ces domaines là et
donc sa garantie la durabilité des
perspectives scientifiques
une vingtaine de scientifiques français
et étrangers travaillent dans cette
infrastructure
lors de la visite ils ont pu échanger
avec thierry mandon sur leurs recherches
ils n'augurait en 2013 par le cnrs et le
ministère de la culture libanais m'a
permet de recueillir de précieuses
informations sur notre histoire grâce à
des techniques les avancées ça permet
d'approfondir l'étude des matériaux
patrimoniaux aucun matériau
paléontologique archéologique de des
collections des musées d'en comprendre
les modes de fabrication l'origine et
les processus d'altération c'était une
très bonne chose de formaliser ce
partenariat qui va nous permettre de
développer de nouveaux projets nous on
va apporter des moyens humains et
probablement aussi un peu financés au
laboratoire un partenariat qui permettra
d'amener de la recherche universitaire
et de la formation au sein du
laboratoire pour lui vs q c'est une
preuve de cette détermination à s'ouvrir
sur la scène internationale il est temps
à présent de passer à notre chronique du
mercredi il sera question comme chaque
semaine d'environnement avec mélanie
broc et bonsoir mélanésie floral alors
ce soir nous parlons aussi recherche
puisque vous êtes allés à la rencontre
d'un chercheur qui vient d'être primé
par le cnrs le centre national de la
recherche scientifique alors ce
chercheur s'appelle olivier evrard il
travaille au lsce le laboratoire des
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
qu'il a intégré en 2008
le lse est une unité mixte de recherche
du cea le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et aux énergies alternatives du
cnrs et de l'université versailles saint
quentin
olivier evrard travaillent sur le site
du cnrs à j'y suis sur yvette et il fait
partie de la promotion 2016 des
médaillés du sénat chaque année le cnrs
récompense des chercheurs pour leurs
travaux qu'ils soient reconnus ou
prometteurs olivier evrard fait partie
de la promotion de la médaille de bronze
alors au sein du laboratoire
il travaille sur le traçage des
sédiments et des polluants dans les
rivières c'est avant tout un travail de
terrain mais aussi d'un élisons
laboratoire il étudie l'origine des
polluants
impact et leur persistance dans les sols
la médaille de bronze
elle récompense le premier travail d'un
chercheur je vais citer le cnrs à propos
de ces récompenses
ça fait de lui un spécialiste de talent
dans son domaine
cette récompense représente un
encouragement du cnrs à poursuivre des
recherches bien engagé et déjà fait
contre
écoutez la réaction d'olivier marc c'est
agréable d'avoir une lettre du cnrs
disons qu encourager à poursuivre les
recherches
oui c'est agréable à entendre après je
pense que
on fait notre métier comme come to me le
fais donc on a certains certains outils
dont on a la chance d'avoir en
laboratoire qui permet sur des mesures
de radioactivité bas niveau on a
l'occasion d'être super réactif ce qu'on
essaye dans la mesure du possible
d'aller sur le terrain faire nos
prélèvements de lait conditionné de les
analyser d'interpréter les résultats
alors mais la musique nous en plus sur
ce travail qui l'a amené à obtenir cette
médaille de bronze justement alors
olivier vrai travail sur différents
niveaux de radioactivité la majeure
partie des activités du laboratoire se
passe dans un milieu environnemental
classiques comme l'île de france et le
bassin de la seine on y retrouve de la
radioactivité naturelle mais aussi de
l'artificiel qui est presque uniquement
lié aux retombées des essais
thermonucléaire atmosphérique des années
60 et de manière plus limitée des
retombées de l'accident de tchernobyl de
1986 mais olivier evrard et le fce sont
aussi amenés à faire des analyses à
l'étranger on écoute je pense a aussi
été l'attribution d'amener a
certainement été aidée aussi par ce
problème fukushima parce que là on était
vraiment dans un cas de figure où la
substance qu on mesure tous les jours
dans nos échantillons prélevés sous en
france a été émise en grande quantité à
un endroit c'était quand même un cas de
figure c'est unique d'avoir un événement
qui se produit et de pouvoir comprendre
à la fois la redistribution ces
polluants un contexte post accidentelle
mais aussi d'avoir un cas unique
d'études de ce qui se passe même en
condition va dire normal alors pour
rappel l'accident de fukushima il lieu
il ya à peine plus de cinq ans c'était
le 11 mars 2011 au japon
olivier evrard et le lsc son parti sur
le terrain dès l'automne 2011 soit tout
juste six mois après l'accident il
s'agisse il s'agissait de traces et la
dispersion de la contamination le long
des rivières qui draine autour du nuage
de contamination principal là que la
contamination n'était pas figé puisque
les substances radioactives se sont
fixés sur les argiles et les limons et
ont suivi la particule pendant son
cheminement dans les rivières
est ce qu'il vous a dit à mélanie sur
quoi porterait ses prochaines recherches
alors sa prochaine étude ce sera en
nouvelle calédonie avec les mines de
nickel pour arriver aux couche de nickel
il fallait creuser
ce qui a donné de la matière très
importante qui ensuite s'est écoulé dans
les rivières en contrebas et a réduit le
début de ces rivières olivier evrard
partir à étudier la provenance de ces
particules et pourquoi pas être
distingué d'une nouvelle médaille du
cnrs en tout cas pour ce qui est celle
de la médaille de bronze
il la recevra officiellement à l'automne
prochain et on lui adresse toutes nos
félicitations merci beaucoup mélanine on
vous retrouve mercredi prochain tour une
nouvelle chronique tout autre sujet à
présent vous connaissez sûrement le
crowfunding les plates formes de
financement participatif comme lille ou
encore kiss kiss bonbons mais
connaissez-vous fundi mot nouvelle
plateforme nouvelle plateforme pardon
spécialisé dans l'immobilier elle permet
aux particuliers d'investir dans
différents projets comme celui d'un
bâtiment d'activité à maurepas
les explications de fanny bourdon
démocratiser l'investissement immobilier
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé foehn
dit mot cette start up lancée en
novembre dernier par trois entrepreneurs
est une plateforme de financement
participatif spécialisé dans
l'immobilier
l'immobilier est un investissement qui
n'était jusqu'à présent pas accessible
pour les particuliers pour monsieur tout
le monde et aujourd'hui grâce au
crowdfunding c'est possible vous pouvez
financer la construction la
réhabilitation d'actifs immobiliers dans
votre région grâce à ce nouveau canal
d'investissement internet
pionnière en la matière fait dix morts
répond à la réglementation actuelle en
étant agréé auprès de l'autorité des
marchés financiers la plateforme propose
déjà cinq projets immobiliers sur son
site
parmi eux le projet paris ouest à
maurepas avec la réalisation d'un
bâtiment d'activité de 5200 mètres
carrés au fond du mot a choisi la zone
de meurent pas et notamment la zone de
paris ouest
de par son attractivité avec les grands
axes routiers de l'ouest parisien
l'autoroute a12 l'autoroute a13
nationale 10 et notamment également de
par son attractivité en termes de prix
j'ai qui ont déjà été réalisés sur la
zone de paris ouest le projet de
réhabilitation réhabilitation
d'immeubles d'activité et notamment de
rénovation d'immeubles existants
un site de crowdfunding simple à
utiliser en quelques clics et à partir
de 1000 euros le souscripteur investi
dans le projet immobilier auquel il
croit une nouvelle façon d'investir en
court circuitant les intermédiaires
traditionnels
nous sommes également une plateforme
indépendante puisque nous nous sommes
associés à aucun promoteur ni aucune
banque qui nous garantit une dépendance
totale dans l'analyse des dossiers et
dans la sélection des projets qui que
mène la plateforme avec un taux de
rendement annuel de 8 à 12% par projet
la plateforme rencontre un franc succès
pour 2016 une quinzaine de projets
immobiliers sont déjà en préparation et
samedi 26 mars se tiendra à villes pro
l'assemblée générale des diabétiques des
yvelines pour nous en parler ce soir
martine roux rival président de
l'association des diabétiques des
yvelines dont saura vous une soit versée
d'être venu sur notre plateau alors lors
de cette assemblée il sera question des
innovations technologiques élaboré pour
les diabétiques
car il ya eu beaucoup d'avancées dans ce
domaine tout à fait tout à fait lors de
cette assemblée nous aurons là
différents intervenants et notamment un
laboratoire qui viendra nous présenter
le nouveau lecteur de glycémie
le freestyle que beaucoup de personnes
diabétiques aujourd'hui utilisent mais
qui malheureusement ce jour n'est
toujours pas remboursé par la sécurité
sociale
c'est un système qui permet à chacun de
pouvoir contrôler sa glycémie uniquement
grâce à un capteur et sans pour autant
devoir se piquer des extrémités des
doigts ce qui rend beaucoup plus
agréable quand même la prise en charge
du diabète
donc cela va changer beaucoup le
quotidien finalement des malades des
diabétiques également des enfants
puisque la grosse problématique aussi
tourner au niveau des enfants
nous aurons également l'intervention des
paramédicaux de la clim de trappes qui
viendra également qui viendront nous
présenter également le nouveau la
nouvelle pompe à insuline associé à un
capteur de glucose qui est également une
nouveauté
donc je pense que ce sera un moment
idéal pour pouvoir avoir une bonne
compréhension de tous ces nouveaux
outils
donc finalement la recherche investi
un petit peu et met les moyens pour
aider à les personnes qui sont atteints
du diabète
nous sommes en pleine innovations au
niveau du diabète la vie des gens
aujourd'hui atteints par cette
pathologie qui malheureusement est
chronique et qui ne se guérit pas dans
le temps voit apparaître de nouvelles
technologies dont le but sera forcément
d'améliorer leurs conditions de vie au
quotidien ça c'est une plus-value énorme
pour cheikh
alors vous avez quelques 200 adhérents
un petit peu plus dans votre association
beaucoup plus de gens sont touchés
globalement dans les yvelines par
justement le diabète le diabète touche
pas forcément les habitants des yvelines
c'est une maladie pandémique 1 qui
aujourd'hui au niveau mondial on se
retrouve à peu près avec 285 millions
d'individus touchés par cette maladie en
france on est à peu près à 3,5 millions
d'individus
mais ce qui est important de souligner
ce sont les 700000 qui s'ignorent
quotidiennement et que l'on ne va pas
forcément détecter immédiatement mais
qui seront détectés avec l'apparition
malheureusement des premières
complications
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir un bon suivi même
si nous ne sommes pas atteints par cette
pathologie
il faut regarder un petit peu dans les
familles voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe et ne pas hésiter au décours d'un
d'un prélèvement de sang ben on regarde
sa glycémie et sa seule le médecin
traitant pourra également vous dire ce
qu'il en est alors justement votre
association fait beaucoup dans ce cadre
là vous faites beaucoup d'actions de
prévention mais aussi d'éducation
thérapeutique c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît moins ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus alors dans un premier
temps l'association des diabétiques des
yvelines a quand même plusieurs missions
mission d'information de prévention de
défense également des intérêts de chaque
individu touchées par cette maladie mais
également de d'accompagnement est
justement dans l'accompagnement
aujourd'hui nous avons le plan élan
solidaire qui est dit mais en place
depuis 2008 et qui permet à
l'association française des yvelines
grâce à la formation de personnes
diabétiques formé en tant que patient
bénévoles experts d'intervenir dans ces
groupes d'éducation thérapeutique
nous ne prenons en aucun cas la place
des médicaux et des paramédicaux dans
cette éducation thérapeutique mais nous
intervenons dans
l'accompagnement puisqu'il faut savoir
que cette maladie
en plus d'avoir cette chronicité et ses
traitements
il ya également tous des modifications
que cela va entraîner dans la vie
quotidienne de chacun et ça c'est
quelque chose d'important puisque en
dehors du secteur hospitalier chaque
individu se retrouve face à ces
problématiques
et là nous sommes là pour les
accompagner et les informer alors donc
l'éducation thérapeutique c'est fait par
des gens qui sont concernés par la
maladie avec son patient soit qu'ils
sont des familles justement des
diabétiques pour chercher justement des
bénévoles pour vos actions oui
actuellement mais il ne s'agit pas
uniquement de l'association française
des diabétiques je pense qu'aujourd'hui
le milieu associatif souffre cruellement
du manque de bénévoles et c'est notre
cas donc j'ouvre vraiment de manière
ouvert à tous cette porte de pouvoir
venir nous rejoindre et nous donner nous
consacrer un petit peu de temps pour
pouvoir nous aider dans toutes les
démarches que nous effectuons puisque
nous avons quand même différentes
missions nous intervenons dans des
conférences débats des ateliers des
stands des conférences des forums santé
n'oublions pas qu'il y aura la journée
mondiale de la santé qui aura lieu donc
le 7 avril et qui va permettre de
sensibiliser d'habitude davantage sur le
diabète et notamment de réfléchir à
cette prévention
nous aurons également la semaine
nationale du diabète le 3 juin une date
à retenir également où il y aura tout un
ensemble de deux moyens qui seront mis
en place sur le sur la france puisque il
n'y a pas que l'association française
des yvelines
il y a également d'autres associations
qui ont les mêmes actions que nous on
agit chacun en fonction des moyens que
nous avons à ça qu'il ya beaucoup
d'associations notamment au niveau de la
santé mais ça que les le diabète est
peut-être moins mis en avant on vraiment
de campagne de prévention ou justement
de sensibilisation à propos du diabète
est ce que selon vous la maladie est
encore méconnue on n'en parle pas
suffisamment alors le diabète est une
maladie qui est connu on en parle sauf
que cette maladie qui est chronique va
toucher toutes les catégories sociales
de la société bien évidemment et dans
cette prise en charge on aura des gens
qui auront des moyens adaptés avec un
encadrement tout à fait suffisant et ils
vont pouvoir continuer à vivre avec
cette maladie
en étant totalement épanouie mais nous
avons également toute une autre partie
de la société qui malheureusement vie
dans une précarité qui est en train de
s'accroître dans le temps et là par
contre il faut vraiment les accompagner
et c'est vraiment toute cette partie de
population qui aujourd'hui est en train
de prendre
quand même de l'importance dans cette
société et c'est sur cette partie de
population que le travail est vraiment
important
la formation existe la prévention
existent l'accompagnement et à
développer et là il ya tout un travail à
faire encore en profondeur une dernière
question avant que notre entretien à
touche à sa fin vous allez faire des
actions justement avec des diététiciens
pour justement que les enfants soient
plus informés peut-être plus prise en
charge notamment attrape alors au niveau
de l'institut de la promotion de la
santé où se trouve notre nos bureaux en
fait nous allons mettre en place une
permanence le premier mardi de chaque
mois à partir du mois d'avril avec la
présence d'une diététicienne qui
accueillera que ce soit voilà des
familles avec des enfants voire des
adultes tout simplement et pouvoir leur
prodiguer des conseils au niveau de
l'alimentation puisque encore une fois
vous avez toutes les tous les conseils
qui sont donnés en secteur hospitalier
etc
mais une fois que vous vous retrouvez
seul à la maison et en fonction encore
une fois de vos moyens de votre mode de
vie
il n'est pas toujours facile d'adapter
merci beaucoup
pardon excusez moi martin morival alors
je le rappelle donc c'est samedi 26 mars
à l'assemblée générale des diabétiques
des yvelines qui se tiendra à villepreux
si vous voulez plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas à consulter le site
internet
afp ce sont uniquement affaire qui se
trouve en bas de votre écran et depuis
la rentrée scolaire plus d'une vingtaine
de classes élémentaires ini mountain
bénéficient du dispositif national école
et cinéma ce programme permet de
développer chez les plus jeunes une
culture cinématographique hémato
graphique pardon sephora namani et
patrick jacques de dixmude se sont
rendus à la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux pour la troisième
projection des classes de ce2 cm1 et cm2
de l'école poirier saint martin on
regarde cette hausse suit maintenant
cette bicyclette
selon toi qu'est ce qu'elle apporte elle
signifie quoi pourquoi il ya une
bicyclette dans les trois films elle
représente quoi
laliberté exactement dans le voleur leur
est restée interdite devant un film
autant d'émotion que le dispositif
national école et cinéma offre aux
enfants de quatre écoles ini monteyne au
cinéma jacques brel trois films
différents choisis pour leurs vertus
pédagogiques sont diffusés aux élèves
d'une vingtaine de classes pour
illustrer la diversité des genres des
époques et des sensibilités du
patrimoine du septième art ça nous
paraît être un billet évident à mettre
en place
voilà pour pour leur permettre de
s'approcher d'une certaine forme de
culture et notamment de mettre tout le
monde sur un pied d'égalité donc au
moins on sait que à l'école tous les
enfants ont la possibilité de de pouvoir
assister à la projection de films qui
font partie du patrimoine français
ces films permettent de découvrir des
langues étrangères par la version
originale et le noir et blanc
ces projections sont ensuite accompagné
d'une action pédagogique menée par la
direction de la culture de la ville
l'enseignant dispose également d'un
livret pour chaque enfant afin de
poursuivre le travail d'exploitation du
film en classe on parle de ce qui s'est
passé pendant la fin de ce qu'on a vu
des points communs entre tous les films
on voit comment si c'est dans le temps
par exemple un voleur de bicyclette
d'envoi jetta on voit qu'il ya des pays
qui ont moins de chance que nous qui qui
n'ont pas autant de liberté que nous
donc c'est bien de voir
différence on étudie chaque film alors
que chez nous on peut voir de si on n'en
parle pas ce dispositif en cours
d'expérimentation cette année devrait
être renouvelée l'an prochain il
complète pour la ville les dispositifs
collège et cinéma et lycéens et
apprentis au cinéma et enfin avant de
nous quitter cette information qui est
tombée aujourd'hui selon les données
transmises par airparif
le seuil de pollution atmosphérique aux
particules sera atteint le jeudi 24 mars
donc demain le préférer la préfecture
conseille à la population et plus
spécifiquement aux catégories de la
population particulièrement vulnérables
comme les femmes enceintes les
nourrissons les jeunes enfants de
réduire ou d'éviter les activités
physiques sportives intenses il est
également conseillé d'emprunter
prioritairement les réseaux de
transports en commun de privilégier les
modes d actifs de déplacement comme le
vélo ou la marche
le covoiturage est de réduire votre
vitesse sur l'ensemble de la région ile
de france vous êtes prévenus vous la
prenez vos précautions tout de suite
vous retrouvez sephora namani pour un
nouveau numéro de kiosques que votre
magazine culturel sur saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
retrouve demain à la même heure pour le
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée